honestly my disappointment
my disgust at the whole thing my
i mean i mean i don't even know i don't
have enough words to actually tell you
how i feel about about about the way
everything turned around
about how much hope there was a spent in
this country how much hope was given to
the people of this country
what was the fault of the people of this
country they stood like a brother next
to
to the international soldiers of the
world americans or
or anybody else shoulder to shoulder
they all went and fought a war and they
all
either came out you know uh winners or
losers but they were together
and they were and they were there was
not a single thing
that was asked of these soldiers i know
that they would have denied
their their officers they didn't do that
how come they can suddenly be dropped
like this
you know without any kind of a support
without anything behind them
without just just like that and and in a
government
that has absolutely no idea
what they are doing they have lost it
completely
i know anytime when i open my mouth and
i say that there are a lot of people
that they put a stamp on me and say oh
you're doing publicity for taliban
no i'm not doing publicity for tolerable
i'm trying to say the truth
of what it is and how it's happening how
it's unfolding
this is not the way to do it this is not
the right way and if
if they want to surrender surrender has
ways of doing it
you don't kill your soldiers put them
into into harm's way
till the last second and then surrender
no
if you have a plan of surrender then at
least save their lives
for god's sakes that is not happening
there is a complete silence from the
government side
they are not saying a word about
anything and then
and then there's this killing there's
this maiming there is this
this this horror that is going on and
and the lack of uncertainty by all of us
because we don't really know what is
going on
we have absolutely there is no i mean
you can ask me a hundred questions about
what do you think is going to happen to
afghanistan i cannot tell you of all of
the millions possibilities
there might be a million of the million
in one possible probability that will
happen
there is nobody knows what's going to
happen and then leaving
leaving this country like that at this
time in the world
it's like dear god what the world is
thinking